hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2020 russian science fiction and action
movie called cosmoball
the movie begins with a flashback story
told by an alien who was a member of the
galactic council
many years ago his leader bello battled
with cherno and engulfed the universe in
war
cherno used his powerful weapon called
the wave eater consuming everything it
touches bellow assembled his best
fighters who can teleport to fight back
cherno he crashed cherno's ship
splitting the earth's moon in the
process
cherno used an escape pod but he was
already chained by bellows armies deep
within the earth the battle reversed
earth's poles changed climates and
caused hardships on its inhabitants
years after the event three earth
inhabitants were born with a special
ability to teleport and they become
athletes the narrator is now guarding
cherno in his prison hoping cherno gets
weaker by day so that his duty is
finished and he can return to his family
meanwhile in now tropical russia people
are queueing for water from a well
including anton he seems like an
ordinary earthling who is afraid of
lizards
when queueing he is nearly killed by a
falling lamppost people are looking down
on him as he is rumored to bring bad
luck the falling lamp post is actually
caused by anya cerno's daughter
she is tasked to ignite the protege
cherno's creation which is trapped
within anton's body she thought that
nearly killing anton would activate the
protege and give enough energy for his
father to escape from prison however
chernow deduces that anya might need to
kill anton to activate the protege after
getting his water anton applies for a
job but is ignored as all earthlings are
excited to watch the cosmo ball an
equivalent of soccer played by a team of
four which anton does not like
the match is broadcast live from the
dandelion a hovering alien ship above
earth that also functions as a stadium
each ball should be kicked five times
before the team can score a goal
the current match is between the earth
team consisting of athletes natasha fan
and pele against the sea russian team
after a dramatic turn of events the
match ends by a draw in the earthling
secure a ticket to the grand final turns
out the ball used in cosmo ball is
actually harvested from cherno's wave
eaters however he manages to steal back
a wave eater killing the prison guards
in the process
bello now the cosmo ball game master is
aware of this and becomes concerned
back on earth anton goes home to find
his mother's medicine has run out then
rushes to a nearby drugstore to steal
the medicine a girl mysteriously appears
and helps him then they escape from the
policeman anton is separated from the
girl and is hit by a moving truck which
nearly kills him the shock causes him to
suddenly teleport noticed by bello the
truck is driven by anya disguised as an
old man
the girl brings anton to her underground
hideout asks him how he escaped and why
he helped her still recovering from the
shock of nearly dying anton does not
answer the questions then the girl
proceeds to seduce him he reacts coldly
then she messes his hair
however he notices that she does not
like cosmoball and he feels attracted as
almost everyone on earth is addicted to
the game he quickly leaves aiming to
give his mother her much needed medicine
turns out the girl is also a disguise of
anya and she successfully took several
strands of anton's hair
she brought them to her father who uses
them to activate his invention
however it does not provide enough
energy cherno insists that anya must
kill anton although she is doubtful
back at home anton is shocked to find
the cosmo ball team already paying him a
visit asking him to join the team
because he can teleport he is puzzled by
the offer and states that he needs to
take care of his mom
fellow ensures that they will find a way
to cure his mom if he joins the team to
which anton agrees they go to the
dandelion the flying stadium facility
anton is mesmerized by the facility's
technology and notices that he cannot
bring any harmful substance inside or
will get destroyed by the dandelion
security system he also gets his own
sputnik a robotic personal assistant
which is supposed to bond with him but
he seems reluctant to bond with him at
the first training session anton is
confused and cannot control his
teleportation ability even when bello
instills fear and natasha takes him on a
flight however when hit by many energy
balls he is finally able to control his
powers and decide to hit the balls using
his hands
fan notices that anton's energy spark
during teleportation is blue unlike the
other's yellowish red spark his powers
also immense fascinating bellow natasha
and the others they decide to make him
the team's goalkeeper
bella leaves the training room and takes
natasha with him they attended video
call with the intergalactic council
which refuses to deliver medicine to
help anton's mother as it is against the
law
however bello insists on helping her to
not lose anton as he is the best
goalkeeper anton and natasha then go to
anton's house and natasha is treating
her while anton is greeted by a
mysterious boy outside his window the
boy tells him that anya wants to meet
him
anton rushes to anya's hideout leaving
his offline sputnik behind anya notices
that anton is now an athlete but he
convinces her that he still does not
like cosmoball
she gives him a piece of plan to extract
the power of the dandelion from inside
so the dandelions energy will wear off
and there will be no more cosmo ball
anton sputnik catches up to him followed
by natasha she asks anton to quickly
leave with her and go back to the
dandelion
preparing for the final match against
amazonians anton seems really reluctant
even when his sputnik provides him with
his protective suit he insists on taking
off his glove so he can reach out for
the plant on you gave him but his
sputnik initially refuses
however he succeeds dropping the plant
someplace in the quarter then joins the
rest of the team in the field he only
watches the game and does not do
anything enraging the supporters
natasha is frustrated then bellow
interrupts the game
anton screams that they are lying to him
as they cannot help cure his mother
natasha quickly shows him a video
showing his mother being alive and well
and is now watching the game bello takes
anton out of the field to a big room
deep inside the dandelion there bello
explains the origin of the energy balls
it is actually a wave-eater a brilliant
weapon invented by cherno he is held
underground in his lab deep within the
earth and cannot be killed as killing
him would involve exploding the earth as
well
bellow invented the famous cosmoball
game to keep cherno's wave eaters
threats in check it can be deactivated
after being kicked five times by the
athletes the athletes are trained to
face the wave eaters massive energy and
they actually know they risk dying if
hit by them cherno's last invention is
the protege seemingly lost when his lab
crashed into earth but it was actually
embedded within anton's jeans and gave
him his distinctive blue sparks during
teleportation
hearing this anton realizes he had
messed up and quickly runs back to where
he left the plant given by anya but it
has already grown and infected the
dandelion he runs back to the field
screaming that the stadium is infected
and everyone is not safe there bello
notices the infected part of the stadium
then immediately turns on the evacuation
protocols natasha is saving a trap
spectator when the wave eater almost
hits her but she is teleported by anton
anton also manages to hit the wave eater
five times until it wears off anton
rushes to anya's hideout after trapping
his sputnik not wanting it to come with
him
unfortunately anya poisons him and
explains that she has been following him
all his life instilling his fear of
lizards and bringing him bad luck in
accidents if he succeeded in destroying
the dandelion she expected that they
could be together but since he failed
she decides to kill him
anton sputnik finally escapes the trap
and immediately rushes to where his body
lies followed by bellow and natasha
sputnik mourns and sacrifices himself to
save anton killing himself
natasha notices cherno's hologram in the
hideout saying that he misses bello his
creator bella refuses to explain more
about the statement and summons all
athletes instructing them to spread out
and keep the earth safe from wave eaters
threats
then he takes off with the dandelion and
goes to outer space
meanwhile cherno and anya succeed in
escaping from the earth using a white
beast that he controls from within he
attacks the galactic fleet and
overpowers them while launching wave
eaters to earth the athletes are busy
keeping the wave eaters from reaching
the earth's surface while anton mourns
his dying sputnik and regrets his
mistakes at home
her mother advises him to get back up
and resolve his mistakes then evacuate
with all other earthlings to underground
subway tunnels
anton now finding his spirit and power
back quickly joins his fellow athletes
to defend the earth even without his
suit he learns that fan is hurt and
rushes her to safety in earthlings hands
fan notices that anton cannot hear what
the other athletes say or warn because
he does not wear his suit and helmet
causing him to be hit by an unexpected
wave eater however he survives the hit
even seems to absorb the wave eater's
energy his sputnik mowgli finally
recovers and provides his suit and
helmet again
then anton immediately aids the other
athletes and uses his immense power to
battle the wave eaters
on the other hand natasha sneaks into
bellows ship confronting him about
cherno's statement bellow explains that
cherno was also his great creation but
cherno's feelings made him
uncontrollable and now he intended to
conquer the universe he hands over the
dandelion to natasha's command then
intends to go back to earth but natasha
teleports both of them to cherno ship
there bello reveals his true form and
battles cherno while natasha battles on
you anton comes to aid bello and natasha
but cherno almost overpowers them all
killing bellow and even anya trapped
within the wall anton learns that the
ship is actually a beast and he can
communicate with it turns out the beast
is just a little kid of his species and
he decides to help anton refusing cherno
to take control of him any longer the
beast dumps cherno anya and the wave
eaters out killing chernow and exploding
the wave eaters the earth is now safe
once more with natasha controlling the
dandelion the broken moon is restored
and anton finds happiness with his mom
and fellow athletes
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching